un acuerdo para poner fin a seis semanas
de combates armenia y azerbaiyán
acordaron un cese completo de las
hostilidades bajo oficio de rusia que
desplegará tropas para garantizar su
cumplimiento
hacia las relaciones que eres pública y
eres pública armenia azerbayán y
armenios frenan los combates en sus
posiciones actuales a lo largo de la
línea de contacto en nagorno karabaj y
el corredor entre nagorno karabakh y la
república de armenia fuerzas para el
mantenimiento de la paz serán
desplegadas network skin england resiste
y francia
con este acuerdo azerbaiyán mantendrá
los territorios recuperados durante el
conflicto incluida la ciudad de suya y
las fuerzas armenias deberán ceder el
control de otras áreas antes del 1 de
diciembre un duro golpe para los
armenios que consideran como propia a
nagorno karabaj una región ubicada en
azerbaiyán pero habitada mayormente por
la etnia armenia
tras el anuncio manifestantes
irrumpieron en el edificio del gobierno
armenio en yereván al grito de no
entregaremos nuestra tierra aunque
aceptó el acuerdo el primer ministro se
mostró dolido por el pacto
el texto de la declaración es muy
doloroso para mí y para nuestro pueblo
la decisión está basada en el hecho de
que la situación actual es el mejor
final posible el acuerdo también
contempla el intercambio de prisioneros
el regreso de desplazados y el
desbloqueo de contactos económicos y de
transporte
el pacto llegó horas después de que
azerbaiyán tomara el control de su ya la
segunda ciudad más grande de la región y
un punto estratégico para el conflicto
por encontrarse en un terreno elevado el
gobierno azerbaiyano también celebró el
acuerdo y señaló que significa la
capitulación de armenia los combates en
nagorno karabaj iniciados a finales de
septiembre resultaron en la muerte de
alrededor de 1000 personas